j'ai commencé tout fait donc le 30 mars
on me descend en urgence en réanimation
là je suis un tube est mis en sommeil
artificiel
jusqu'au 12
c'est quand même une longue période
je suis resté entre eux entre la vie et
la mort
voilà et à partir du 12 je suis réveillé
ont repris en mer puis recharge etc
étaient en bolatti vise beaucoup de
choses la vie pourrait complètement un
autre sens je suis resté longtemps ici
ça m'a permis de beaucoup de réfléchir
de faire un peu le point
on a maintenant je me sens mieux je me
sens mieux puisque je tique l'hôpital
aujourd'hui on m'a arraché de la mort je
crois que tous mes amis pensaient que
c'était à peu près foutu et et beaucoup
ont été heureusement surpris et est
comme moi même de la rapidité avec
laquelle j'ai ré émerger de cette
maladie donc c'est un gros merci du fond
du coeur
un grand merci du fond du coeur est et
que je voulais que les martiniquais
prennent conscience que qu'ils ont là
des sacrée équipe
c'est pas tant les compétences parce que
je pense il ya des compétences partout
il ya une motivation vraiment une grande
motivation